l'année 2023 va certainement être
palpitantes il y aura une transformation
majeure des moteurs de recherche avec le
développement d'outils comme tchat GPT
je sais pas si vous le connaissez on en
parle partout on a la semité pour nos
parler de chat GPT et des règles
d'éthique en tourant l'utilisation d'un
tel robot est-ce que c'est l'avenir
est-ce que ça risque d'encourager la
paresse et la facilité comme certains le
craignent est-ce que je pourrais faire
toutes mes entrevues avec chaque GPT
puis j'ai juste à répéter les questions
en tout cas j'en parle avec Joshua
benjood titulaire à l'Université de
Montréal fondateur et directeur
scientifique de Milan l'Institut
québécois d'intelligence artificielle
bonsoir Monsieur Benjo alors il y a
tellement de questions qui se posent
d'abord nous décrivez nous tchat GPT le
nouvel ami devient des gens c'est un
système de dialogue c'est à dire la
machine a été entraînée sur à peu près
tous les textes qui sont écrits et elle
est entraînée à imiter comment un humain
répondrait à des questions et donc c'est
un système qui répond à des questions et
on peut avoir un dialogue avec plusieurs
questions-réponses
en même temps c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très mécanique c'est pas un
système qui a sa propre initiative une
idée de soi c'est quelque chose qui
dérive des recherches entre autres qu'on
a fait à Montréal depuis des décennies
sur
l'apprentissage profond est-ce que je
posais la question en présentation
est-ce que ça fait encourager la paresse
et la facilité est-ce que ça peut
recréer la pensée d'un cerveau humain
alors on est loin de recréer la pensée
d'un cerveau humain et encore beaucoup
de différence et de capacité de notre
intellect qui manque à ces systèmes là
mais éventuellement
nous-même on est des machines
biologiques on va figurer comment
comment ça marche de plus en plus et on
va pouvoir construire des machines qui
ont des capacités semblables et
un pas dans cette direction
est-ce que c'est ma chaîne là sont
capables de quand même d'une forme de
d'intelligence oui il y a qu'à voir ce
qu'elles sont capables de faire
dans le monde de l'enseignement on crée
beaucoup le recours à chat GPT
exactement parce que on peut demander à
la machine de nous écrire un texte sur
un sujet précis en un certain nombre de
mots et elle va faire quelque chose qui
linguistiquement et est bon très bon il
y a pas de fautes d'ailleurs c'est une
manière de détecter que c'est
probablement la chienne
par contre si on pose des questions
assez pointues on va se rendre compte
que des fois elle va dire des choses
fausses et qu'elle est pas toujours
parfaitement cohérente donc il y a des
enjeux on n'est pas rendu encore à
quelque chose d'aussi bon qu'un humain
mais pour des élèves qui voudraient
tricher finalement ça serait une voix
facile est-ce que dans le pas parce que
pas du plagié à cette
un étudiant ça sera un vol de contenu à
votre création artificielle de contenu
oui par contre il y a un logiciel que la
même organisation qui a sorti chat GPT
donc au
ils ont sorti un logiciel qui a été
entraîné pour détecter un texte vient de
GPT plutôt qu'un humain et si le texte
est suffisamment long comme un essai
pour un devoir il va le détecter à si
facilement est-ce que c'est une avancée
oui c'est une avancée disons
technologique au point de vue
scientifique premièrement ils ont pas
révélé les détails mais si on se fie à
ce qu'on connaît de ce qu'ils font et de
ce qui se passe dans la communauté c'est
essentiellement les ingrédients qu'on
connaît mais à grande échelle avec
beaucoup d'ingénierie pour faire
vraiment marcher ce bien de façon à ce
que les gens aiment le dialogue et voilà
c'est pour nourrir la bête en fait c'est
nourri avec peu près tout ce qui a été
écrit et qui est disponible sur Internet
est-ce qu'on sait qui contrôle la bête
la machine la compagnie open est-ce que
vous imaginez que ça leur prend beaucoup
de monde beaucoup d'ingénieurs beaucoup
de technologues non c'est pas très gros
c'est pas très gros mais ils ont besoin
de puissance de calcul
qu'ils ont obtenu en partie de Microsoft
donc c'est une petite organisation je
connais pas le nombre d'employés mais
c'est le nombre de chercheurs ça doit
pas plus que quelques dizaines est-ce
qu'on demande aux ordinateurs de
travailler ou de même penser à notre
place quand on fait à faire avec une
machine comme ça le robot
ça peut jouer ce rôle ça peut être aussi
d'une manière de nous aider à penser un
peu comme est-ce que Wikipédia nous
empêche de pencher de penser on peut
l'utiliser pour aller chercher de
l'information qu'on n'avait pas donc ça
peut nous aider dans notre réflexion
donc tchat j'ai petit peut nous donner
des idées sur un sujet qu'on connaît pas
suffisamment mais au lieu d'avoir à
chercher dans Wikipédia ou sur Google on
tape une question en français il va nous
donner des réponses dans notre langue en
plus même pas en anglais ça marche pour
beaucoup de langues en plus alors
écoutez on a fait un petit test vous
avez accepté qu'on fasse par là on a
demandé on a de la difficulté à aller
sur
c'est très très achalandé vers 18h ça
c'est c'était possible on a demandé à
jppy qu'est-ce que Yoshua benjour
répondrait si on lui demandait est-ce
que tchat était une nuit à notre
capacité de passer et de raisonner par
nous-mêmes
la réponse que je donnerai en général
pour l'intelligence artificielle et tous
les outils puissant comme ça ça dépend
de l'utilisation qu'on en fait donc
c'est important de l'encadrer si on
l'utilise comme un outil qui nous permet
de
d'aller chercher de l'information plus
facilement tout simplement par exemple
ça peut être très intéressant si cet
outil est augmenté pour citer ses
sources qui est pas le cas actuellement
ce sera encore plus utile par contre si
ça devient quelque chose qui nous permet
de paresseux de faire le travail par
quelqu'un d'autre mais ça dépend si on
n'a pas beaucoup de temps pour faire
quelque chose puis qu'on a besoin de ça
ça peut être utile mais si c'est dans le
cadre de l'éducation de l'enseignement
où on a besoin que les élèves
développent leur propre capacité à
réfléchir par eux-mêmes donc là c'est un
problème et je pense que les écoles les
universités vont pouvoir encadrer ça
parce qu'il y a des logiciels parce
qu'il faut mettre des règles nouvelles
puis c'est pas seulement à l'université
je pense qu'il faut des règles pour
encadrer l'intelligence
alors je ne suis pas en mesure de
prédire comment Yoshua Benjo répondra à
cette question mais il est possible
qu'ils disent que si les modèles de
langage comme JPP peuvent fournir des
informations utiles aider à les
résolution de problèmes il est important
que les utilisent leur propre pensée
critique et de raisonnement plutôt que
de s'appuyer uniquement sur la sortie
d'un modèle de langage j'ai pété vous
connaissez beaucoup que je continue de
plus il est également important d'être
conscient des limites et des billets
potentiels des modèles linguistiques et
de les utiliser de manière responsable
quelle note de niveau LGBT là-dessus
très très bonne
alors c'est la preuve au fond que cette
machine-là a toutes les informations sur
robot je sais pas comment on a pu cet
outil à partir de ce que vous avez pu
déclarer écrire exactement
en fait
elle a accès à une quantité de
d'information que aucun être humain aura
accès aujourd'hui mais sa capacité à
raisonner sur cette informations
aujourd'hui encore assez limité puis
toutes les connaissances viennent de ces
données là alors que nous les êtres
humains on peut
on peut se donner des instructions
supplémentaires on peut aller par de là
par exemple les billets qui pouvaient
être dans les données donc on craint que
les systèmes de langage il y a des
exemples
vont reproduire les les biais les
discriminations qui sont dans la manière
dont les gens s'expriment et puis aussi
le problème que j'ai pété a été entraîné
à imiter comment un humain parlerait ce
que ça donne comme résultat c'est que
c'est beau c'est fluide mais au niveau
de la véracité des ce qui est exprimé
c'est pas toujours là et donc faut pas
le prendre pour de l'argent comptant au
pied de la lettre en terminale il y a un
accusé aux États-Unis qui se sert de
notre outil qui est une espèce de robot
ça s'appelle do noter notre entreprise
et au lieu il remplace l'avocat par
par un robot
pour le conseiller
oui c'est ça m'étonne pas que se
développe des systèmes comme ça
aujourd'hui vous savez la justice est
pas très accessible aux commandes des
mortels si des outils d'intelligence
artificielle qui réduisent les coûts ça
va ça va ouvrir un peu plus l'accès à la
justice donc ça peut être une bonne
chose évidemment faut l'encadrer
correctement pour les mêmes raisons que
pour chat gpting merci d'être passé en
studio on en connaît plus sur un chat
GPT et merci les filles c'est limite
merci ça m'a fait plaisir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI